the mag2 is filled with tons of subtle
Easter eggs from dozens of horror movies
did you catch that sneaky foreshadowing
in the finale and did you know everyone
was afraid for Jason Statham's life when
he was doing all of his own stunts that
ski jet scene was just as dangerous as
it looked let's get into it there was a
major plot point at the end of the movie
that they alluded to in the very
beginning leave your theories in the
comments do you remember when maying was
looking at the Meg through the glass and
they shared a little moment together
maying asks do you miss your mom big
fish this is essentially establishing a
connection between the two of them they
have both lost their mothers and are
both grieving loss in a different way
all of this comes into play once we
reach the end of the film we find out
that the Meg is pregnant still out there
maybe pregnant ah preferably not and
this could also be a major foreshadowing
to the next installment could we
possibly see maying become pregnant as
their stories continue to intertwine
over the years only time will tell Jason
Statham is a big fan of doing as many of
his own stunts as physically possible
that remains true for this movie The
majority of the stunt work is all him
even that insane jet ski Chase was done
completely without the help of a
stuntman the director Ben Wheatley was
terrified at the speed Jason was going
on the ski he said we were all at the
monitor saying please come back all
right they also had him set up on a
giant hand drill for those upside down
shots apparently it was because the
physics of a face are really hard to
fake so in every scene where Jason was
shown upside down they actually had to
get him into that position somehow
they'd pull a trigger spin him around
and blast water directly into his face
just another casual day at the office
the Easter eggs in this movie are
abundant that Jurassic Park moment with
the T-Rex was a brilliant chef's kiss
when the Meg came up and devoured it it
was almost as if to say that there's a
new more vicious monster in the
franchise of monster movies indominus
Rex she will be 50 feet long when fully
grown bigger than the T-Rex one of the
biggest films referenced in this movie
is no surprise here Jaws one of the most
most notable shots that pays homage to
the iconic franchise is when the camera
is inside the Meg's mouth as it bites
down on the swimmers it's a direct
reference to the shot in Jaws 3 when the
oceanographer Philip fitzroyce got
attacked and swallowed whole by the
Beast if you thought I was gonna stop
there you were wrong let's talk about
Pippin the dog that unlucky little
Yorkie was shown in the finale of the
first Meg film barely surviving all of
the chaos Pippin also did make it to the
end of Meg too getting caught up in all
the chaos again undoubtedly returning
for Mega 3. what I'm actually getting at
though is that that dog's name is
actually another Jaws reference right
before Alex kinter is attacked a dog
named Pippin who is playing fetch in the
water disappears right before Alex meets
his untimely end it's such a deep cut
sentimental homage to reincarnate Pippin
in all three Meg films let's hope the
resilient Yorkie can make it through a
third round of Chaos
perfect
there's a pivotal scene in the Meg 2
where Jonas bangs a helicopter blade
against the water to lure the Meg over
to him and it's a light reference to
when Brody does the same thing with an
ore against an electric wire in Jaws too
if you've seen Jaws 2 you know that the
shark needs a pretty nasty end because
of this I definitely wouldn't recommend
biting down on electrical wire in any
way shape or form so when the Meg is
lured over Jonas holds up the helicopter
blade and fatally impales the shark the
next shot we see is the shark's body
floating down to the bottom of the ocean
which was the same type of shot used in
Jaws the Revenge when Ellen Brody's
Widow Spears the shark's head with a
broken bow Spirit from her boat there's
a major visual reference that's shown in
the very beginning of the movie when Wu
Jing's juming is attempting to Showcase
how supposedly trained the Meg is by
using a clicker to keep her from
attacking him the spoiler alert it
doesn't really work out as planned she
and ends up charging forward at him and
nearly crashing into a window luckily he
was pulled up just in the nick of time
the entire sequence is actually a
callback to Jaws 3DS hilariously iconic
glass smash shot now I would definitely
say that the Meg's special effects are
Miles Ahead naturally so the scene's not
necessarily as funny as in Jaws 3D but I
will always appreciate a reference to it
in like anyway they did a full send with
a major glass Break scene which is
probably what jaws 3D was trying to
accomplish at the time now if only we
could get a call back to the shark
explosion scene from Jaws 3D maybe in
neg3 the Meg 2 brings classic Jaws
energy to life in a modern way while
still keeping the audiences on their
toes with the Cinematic shots to the
bottom of the ocean that brings you
right back to Jaws Revenge the glass
smash shot no one could ever forget from
the iconic 1983 movie meg2 doesn't miss
a Beat
[Music]